so we have 0.79 minus 4/3 minus 1/2 plus
150% so we have four different numbers
written in different formats here it's a
decimal here we have two fractions and
then here we have a percentage so the
easiest thing to do would be to write
all of these in the same format and for
me the easiest format to do this
computation in would be to write them
all as fractions and the reason why I
wanted that in particular is because
four thirds when you divide by three
when you divide a one-third two-thirds
four thirds you're going to have a
repeating decimal so to avoid that I
want to put all of these I want to
rewrite all of these as fractions so
let's do them one at a time so zero
point seven nine this is the same thing
as seventy nine hundredths so I'll just
write it that way so this is the same
thing as 79 over 100 then of course we
have minus 4/3 minus 4/3 then we have
minus 1/2 minus 1/2 and then finally we
have we don't want to run out of colors
here finally we have 150 percent well
150 percent percent literally means per
cent per 100 so this is plus 150 per 100
per hundred so now we've written them
all as fractions in order to do all the
subtraction addition we have to find a
common denominator so what's the comment
what's the least common multiple of 100
3 2 and 100 well 100 is 'visible by 2 so
100 is actually the least common
multiple of 102 so we really have to
just find a least common multiple
between 100 and 300 and that's just
going to be 300 there's no other common
factors between 100 and 3 so let's write
write all of them with 300 as the common
denominator so let me do this in this
reddish color so 79 over 100 is the same
thing if I were to write it over 300 to
go from 100 to 300 in the denominator
I'm multiplying by 3 so after multiply
the numerator by 3 as well so I'm going
to multiply by 3 as well let's see 80
times 3 would be 240 so it's going to be
3 less than that so 200 and
40 minus 3 is 237 now 4/3 well to get
the denominator to be 300 we had to
multiply the denominator by 100 so we
have to multiply the numerator by 100 as
well 1/2 1/2 if our denominator is 300
we multiplied the denominator by 150 to
go from 2 to 300 so we have to multiply
the numerator by 150 and then finally
150 over 300 oh sorry 150 over 100 well
we're multiplying the denominator by 3
to get to 300 to go from 100 to 300 so
we have to do the same thing in the
numerator so 3 times 150 is 450 so now
we have the same denominator and we can
now add our numerators so this is going
to be equal to this is going to be equal
to actually I could just do it right
over here on the right hand side this is
going to be equal to some stuff over 300
so it's going to be 237 237 - 400 - 400
and - 150 - 150 and this actually should
be a plus right over here this should be
plus plus 450 plus 450 and so let's see
what if we could simplify this a little
bit we're subtracting 400 and we're
subtracting 150 so these two would be
the same thing as subtracting 550 and
then we are at we have a positive 237
and we're adding it to a positive 450 or
actually maybe another easier way to
think about this is negative 550 Plus
450 is going to get us negative 100 and
so this simplifies things a good bit now
we have 237 minus 100 is going to be 137
so it equals 137 in the numerator over
over 300 and this is about as simplified
as I
can think of making it and so this is
our final answer 137 over 300